foreign
[Music]
good morning good morning all of you
hope you had a great evening yesterday
and if this is your first session today
morning then welcome to day three of
cloud next
I'm sure by now you would have seen
various different very interesting AIML
and analytics demos and Innovations
which Google cloud is bringing to the
market
in fact if you haven't seen the Wendy's
drive-in at the expo hall I really
encourage you to go and try this it's
really interesting
and I'm sure many of you want to go and
try out some of these projects get it
started in organization
but
and there's always a part for any of
these projects to Really Happen the
first step is moving terabytes or maybe
petabytes of data to Google Cloud
and if you're wondering if this data
transfer at scale is easy
the answer is yes and this is the
session we are going to show you how
my name is manjul sahai I'm one of the
lead product managers for Google Cloud
Storage I'm joined by my colleague
ajitesh who is a product manager for
transfer service
joined by hilame Beren from Global one
of our Marquee stream customers
from our partner thoughtworks
and together
we're essentially going to cover three
things number one
give you an overview of Google cloud
data transfer portfolio
and how it makes transfer really easy
second
we'll talk about best practices for
moving data from on-prem to Cloud
as well as for setting up multi-cloud
data pipeline
and finally
well here the real world
story of global and how thoughtworks
have them migrate to Google cloud and
it's a very interesting one and
hopefully it brings together what we
talk in the earlier parts of the
presentation
great so
before we get started I just want to
recapture that data transfer
tools what we talk about today is a part
of our storage portfolio
and storage Computing networking all of
these together from our workload
optimized infrastructure offering from
Google Cloud
and once again
these services are built to help you run
your aim in the workloads for sure
as well as modern container workloads
and are equally well set to run your
existing workloads like sap VMware and
all that
so let me start it with the first
section to give an overview of the data
transfer portfolio
now there are multiple use cases and
scenarios for data transfer
so there are customers who move data
from on-prem to Cloud
and they may run their own custom
Analytics tool on gke GCE
and there are other customers who are
closing data centers and moving their
workloads to Google Cloud
both of these cases data transfer is a
problem to be solved for
there are many other customers who are
moving data across cloud
and they're setting up multi-cloud data
Pipeline and you will see some very
interesting data points on this maybe
just another two slides down the down
the presentation
again they want to take advantage of
Google Cloud's leading industry-leading
analytics products
and then there are of course customers
who are moving applications from other
Cloud to World cloud
there's also the third scenario which is
customers once they have their data in
Google cloud in Google Cloud Storage
file store
they want to manage that data better and
this could be for Dr reason backup
reason or you know archival
and the tools we will cover today are
the services we talk about today
also help you catered for this third
category
but in the presentation we are going to
focus on the first two scenarios and
share more on that
now data transfer at scale is not easy
if any of you have done this before you
know that performance is a big concern
how do you make sure that you use them
whole of network connection
and don't use so much that you cause
problem for your running application
you want to make sure your compute and
network is optimized
you of course have to on many times
customers end up writing scripts which
they have to manage upgrade all of that
and
how do you make sure that data is
securely transferred
make sure that the Integrity is there
and validated you don't want to delete
your data from the source and then you
find out there are some issues on your
target side
so all this is tough
and the other one which is not there but
there's always a big elephant in the
room cost
how do you do this transfer at the right
cost and not end up where the transfer
itself is 20 30 percent of your overall
product and you know leads to Big
questions on Roi
so moving data at scale is complex
the good news is the Google Cloud
product portfolio in data transfer is
pretty robust and simple and helps you
solve for that
so first we have transfer Appliance you
know I was in a customer conversation
just yesterday you know they're using
this appliances very well they move data
from their regulated environments
on-prem scenarios to Google Cloud using
their clients
there's another very interesting variant
of transfer Appliance if you're not
aware so if you have data getting
generated in Edge like we have a
customer who are using this appliances
with Rovers you can have the data come
to Appliance in an offline scenario and
then whenever the appliance is put in a
connected environment it will move data
to Google Cloud so there's this hybrid
offline online approach also available
with head clients
we have gcloud storage tools which we
recommend for small data transfers for
both on-prem to cloud or within Google
Cloud
and then our most popular tool most
commonly used by customers is storage
transfer service which essentially
caters to all the three scenarios which
is on-prem to Cloud within gcp and
across different Cloud so this is simple
three product portfolio but very robust
been around for a couple of years to
cater to these requirements
now
I believe and you know we think that
these products really make it easy but
nothing better than that you know rather
than taking my word why not you know
here what customers have said about this
so today is the first time we are
sharing this publicly that we have
thousands of customers multiple
thousands I don't mean one thousand one
only thousands of customers who are
moving data every month
from AWS and Azure to Google cloud and
most commonly they use it for running
analytics workloads on Google Cloud
thousands of customers and we have had
this pattern so these customers have
some of these workloads running on other
Cloud they have set up this regular
monthly data Pipeline and then they use
bigquery vertex AI data proc these tools
these services on Google Cloud
so if any of you have been considering
this kind of a multi-cloud scenario
absolutely feel confident that there are
many other customers who do it today and
they've been doing it very successfully
at scale
now if we talk about on-prem to Cloud
again one of our esteemed customer Tim
Brazil they move petabyte scale of data
found it very easy seamless saturating
at 20 gbps connection so again some
proof points to share with you that
these tools have made customers life
easy help them do this transfer at scale
in a seamless way
now let me talk about storage transfer
Service as I shared this is one of our
most popular tools used most commonly by
customers
so
quite a comprehensive set of features
the service has around been a couple of
years so security performance managed
features controls we have built on all
of these different aspects
the two of them which I'll highlight
starting with the first one is over the
last 12 to 24 months we have done a
significant amount of work to really
improve performance to improve that
performance of transfer especially for
small and large files so you know I
would say that the performance which you
would get from Storage transfers is
service is significantly better than
some of the other competitive options
there
the other one which is a recent released
is even driven transfer so you could
have data coming in and using Pub sub
notifications or real-time event have
those data transferred across Cloud to
Google cloud or within Google Cloud for
processing in Google Cloud Storage so
it's a very interesting feature with
this you could start taking use of
vertex AI in some of their real-time
analytics Services even if your data is
not exactly in the same location
so if you haven't you know something
worth checking out if it fits your use
case
and here's a quick recapture of some of
the recent features and releases of
storage transfer Service as well as our
other transfer products what we have
done
I'm not going to go through each of them
but maybe highlight two of them
the first one is a new support for any
S3 compatible object storage so their
customers who may have an S3 compatible
object storage in their on-premise
environments and now you can use that to
transfer data to Google Cloud Storage
or even if you have data in S3 or some
of these other on you know Cloud object
storage offerings this gives you a way
to shape the network by the network
connectivity and data transfer to get
better costs or performance in some
scenarios so it's a very interesting
feature helps with that we're also about
to launch hdfs support So for customers
who are running on-premise defense
environments and they're looking for a
way to move that to Google Cloud we are
going to support that with storage
transfer service again the performance
of this in art as we have found is
significantly better than some of the
other
tools which are available today this is
a service which runs outside of the
cluster so if you're trying to vacate
the cluster you don't have to consume
those resource and you can get
significantly better performance
so once again my section what I wanted
to leave away is we have a pretty robust
set of tools Services which can help you
make the data transfer easy at scale and
again
hopefully you noted some of these
customer testimonials to prove they have
been doing that pretty regularly
I'll now invite ajitesh to come and give
us some best practices details for both
on-prem to cloud and then multi-cloud
transfers ajitesh
thank you manjul so I'll walk you
through the best practices for on-prem
to cloud and multi-cloud data transfer
so starting with the first one
so when it comes to data transfer there
are three critical Parts the first part
is figuring out the planning that what
data sets you'll move and who will do
the data transfer
one thing to note here that legal and
security play a pivotal role they
approve the software that you need to
deploy the hardware that we'll be using
and what data sets move to Cloud so make
sure you engage with all the
stakeholders early in the cycle
the second step is figuring out how to
do the actual transfer
and this has two parts the first is what
transfer tool will you use
for example if you are operating out of
data center where there is low
connectivity and the cost of setting up
link is really high you should use data
transfer Appliance
in the case when you have good
connectivity or want to land data as
quickly as possible use storage transfer
service
the second part of this is what
migration approach should I use
to a large extent this depends on how
much downtime the application which is
using the storage can take
one of the popular approach is
highlighted in this in the bullet 2 here
this is a two-step transfer where you do
the seed transfer that is bulk copy the
data from source to destination and
during this time you keep reading and
writing from the source
when you take a downtime at the source
and do a sync transfer where you capture
the Delta all changes from the source to
destination
this is popular because it results in
minimal downtime and also requires less
engineering effort
once you finalize the approach then you
do the actual transfer and then move to
third step which is validating transfer
there are two approaches to validate
transfer first is to match aggregate
statistics that is total number of bytes
copied total objects copied
or you can go object by object and
compare size and md5
we offer you a couple of options to make
it easy for you
so that's the high level approach next
let me cover specific best practices
when using STS to move data from on-prem
to Cloud
so on the right hand side here is the
high level architecture
so we ask you to download STS agents
which are dockerized application these
agents run on a VM close to the source
and when you create the data transfer
job these agents work in parallel to
read data from the source and write to
the cloud storage bucket
jumping to the best practices in the
planning stage we recommend doing quick
and early POC
in doing the POC make sure you are
testing with one to five terabytes of
data
that's critical because if you are using
less data it will not give you the right
picture STS is designed to operate at
terabytes and petabyte scale
one other thing that we recommend is
don't directly write a colder storage
class if you have to take any corrective
action this will result in high API Ops
and early delete charges
the next one is pertaining to
Performance
if you want to scale performance just
add more STS agents if adding agents
does not lead to higher performance that
means there are bottlenecks in other
part of the system
one of the things that we see commonly
is that in the older storage system you
have lower rate throughput limits so
make sure you are using tools such as
fio to measure the read limits
STS provides lot of Rich controls so
make sure you're using the right one for
example we often see that the data
transfer workload and the operational
workload uses the same network pipe to
read and write from the cloud storage
in that case you don't want transfer to
consume the entire bandwidth
in that case you can use STS bandwidth
control to monitor the and control the
STS bandwidth that STS consumes
and finally make sure you are validating
the transfer we already spoke about
couple of ways you can do that
so that's on the best practices for
on-prem to Cloud side
next let me cover specific best
practices for setting up multi-cloud
data pipeline
so when we speak to customer about this
there are three major consideration the
first and the top one is the egress cost
eager is typically account for 90 to 99
of the transfer cost
and there are multiple ways to egress
data from other cloud
I'll be covering specific details in the
later slides
the second major consideration is
performance and this has two dimension
the first one is throughput
if you want to scale throughput just add
more STS transfer job a single STS job
copies 1000 objects per second and
scales up to 10 000. if you trigger 10
jobs on Parallel prefix you can right
away get 10 000 object copies per second
the second dimension here is latency
for a lot of workload like Predictive
Analytics or low RPO backup you want to
land data as quickly as possible in this
case you can use sts7 driven transfer
here we'll listen to change notification
at the source and copy the data in near
real time
the third factor is security and
reliability to a large extent STS takes
care of this out of the box we encrypt
the data in transit do automatic retries
check some matching
but you can take certain steps to make
it more secure and reliable
for example when giving STS access to
AWS resources make sure you are using
STS Federated identity
in this case STS assumes a role in AWS
environment and generates short-lived
tokens dynamically
these are much more secure than using
long-lived credentials
when it comes to reliability one thing
we recommend is to use cloud logging and
Cloud monitoring with Cloud monitoring
you can get notified when the
performance metrics are down and then
you can use cloud logging to dig deeper
to understand why that happened
we offer multiple options for you to
egress data from AWS S3
simplest and the easiest one is to use
STS and bigquery data transfer service
though they do result in higher egress
charge
another option is to use bigquery Omni
data transfer
this is suitable if you are using
bigquery Omni and want to land data to
BQ
the other two option options highlighted
here in the blue box result in sixty
percent lower egress charge
I'll be covering these options namely
egress via private Network and egress
via Cloud front in the next two slides
so how do you egress data from private
Network sorry
so there are three easy steps
the first step is that you create this
cross-cloud infrastructure
you can use either cross Cloud
interconnect which is a gcp offering to
do that
or you can use third party vendor like
Mega port and equinix to create this
once your network is set up you go to
the gcp site and deploy STS S3
compatible agent on a GCE or gke node
when deploying on the gkgc Node make
sure these node can speak to S3 VPC
endpoint
when this step is done you go to STS
console and create a transfer job that
can speak to S3 VPC endpoint
now your transfer will happen via this
private Network and result in 60 lower
egress charge
couple of things to note on this slide
this requires deploying you this fixed
infrastructure which result in certain
cost and that's why it's more suitable
if you are moving 100 terabytes Plus
data
second when we interact with multiple
customers they also have these top-down
mandates to not use public internet in
that case this offers a viable path and
also much more predictable performance
there is one more approach to egress
data that is via Cloud front
so this is how you set this up the step
one is you create a cloudfront
distribution for your S3 bucket you can
do that going to as AWS console clicking
few buttons
then you come to STS page and create a
transfer job supplying this new Cloud
front domain
now your all transfer will happen in two
steps first it will go from S3 to
cloudfront the Loading which is free and
second that will egress from the cloud
front which is substantially cheaper
couple of things to highlight about this
approach this feature is currently in
the control GA phase so if you want to
get access to this reach out to the
account team they can get you enrolled
second this does not require paying for
any fixed infrastructure so it's
suitable even for a small amount of data
so megabyte terabytes will also do
so that's on the best practices side
next I'll invite on stage our Marquee
customer Global and our Google Cloud's
Premiere partner thoughtworks to walk
you through the successful migration
story of global I'm really excited to
hear that thank you so much everyone
[Applause]
thank you
so my name is Glenn meding I'm from Robo
I manage the Big Data platform things
there
and Global is the largest Media company
in the Latin America
Global Health broadcast channels pay TV
channels and digital products for news
entertainment and sports
Global has more than 100 million users
per month
and Global play that's our streaming
service has more than 30 million paid
entry users in our platform
in 2018 Globe starts this is its digital
transformation behaving the way to
become a media tech company
and thoughtworks was one of the key
Partners helping us in this journey
hi my name is Vera I'm a technical
principal at thoughtworks uh tortoise is
a leading Global consultancy that
integrates strategy
Consulting
software engineering design we
collaborated with global owners project
this project is a super part of a larger
digital transformation of global and
totals is also a premier partners of
Google Cloud
2022 globally created it's all on that
on-premise workloads to gcp
and these workloads are from delivering
all the content for our digital products
Big Data pipelines and back-offs tools
in this presentation I will talk about
how immigrated the global play Big Data
pipelines through the city
so before gcp
this is what's Global play Big Data high
level architecture we have a data
ingestion system that captures user
Behavior
from all all Global digital products
they collect things like page views
video views clicks and everything that
your users interact with the products
in the in that time we use nginx go on
kubernetes and Spark with streaming
Hadoop to store out this data
and Global play process all this data to
with pi spark and Hadoop to understand
how the user is behave in the in the
product
so they can do user engagement and
performance of the content
but this solution has one problem the
it's out to scaling because we need to
predict the highest peak of the year and
provides and all the hazards that we
need in the data center for it
and this approach leaves a lot of idle
resources during the year
so after migrating all the data we
collaborated with global to modernize a
data pipeline from the older proprietary
solution to a solution 100 based on gcp
uh before we get into the technical
details it's important to contextualize
everyone about what business problems
are resolving and how this data will be
used and what business what value will
bring it to to the business
so Global play is a streaming app it
generates a lot of data from the user's
interaction using the app this data we
go into two different domains
the first domain is the marketing domain
where we are answering questions such as
was the performance of our marketing
campaigns how can you engage users more
uh how can they can we reduce users
churn and so on
the second of the main is the
intelligence domain
we answer questions such as how can I
have a 360 view of our users across all
digital products of global what shows a
big watch and so on uh if you one one
interesting aspect of this use cases is
that most of the user cases are designed
for business people they're not uh
uh people with hard coding skills
they're not hardcore programmers so
designing a solution that's easy to
maintain and easy to debug and see
what's going on that was one of the
goals of this project
it expected that these people will
evolve the the solution in the future
create new data products as the business
needs
so
um as I said before there was a Lexi
solution in place for the data
processing
so one important question to ask is why
why do we need to migrate data pipeline
why can't I just use the same data
pipeline that was already in place
I think that this lines trying to show
the rationale behind this decision I
will not go into all the details uh
you can take a look closer uh
there's a a lot of information and we
also have a slide talking a little bit
more about the architecture
uh at the time we had the feeling that
was possible to do something that was
cheaper faster and more easy to maintain
uh but was still a quite vague idea at
the time
so covering two two important topics uh
the first one is cost transparency uh in
the new gcp solution we have no
licensing cost we just pay for the cost
of the workload itself we have much more
control of where this cost is occurring
what's going on whether the lack of
solution was just a single cause for
just
processing and Licensing and we don't
have really visibility what's what's
going on
uh
feature-wise what's uh we were able to
implement new features that was not
possible before or at the least to
improve these features we're talking
here about uh automatic scalability
scalability
easier reprocessing of your jobs
processing only newly generated data and
so on
so after the entire data pipeline was
migrated we measured all the results and
they were outstanding much better than
we have ever imagined without
considering uh improvements in
performance uh
in governance or observability we
managed to
achieve annual cost reduction of 78
percent
that's a big number that's this number
alone justifies why the work was done
and was a great return over investment
for for this project
we also reduce the processing time by 97
percent
data sets volume reduction by 34 failure
reduction by 92 percent
so why so so good results is it magic is
it what uh I think that we've improve it
uh transparency more control we it
became possible to be smarter about the
utilization of resources and processing
strategies and overall optimizations
that was not possible before I think
that's the one of the main reasons
uh of the success of this project in
such a massive uh data set that's a
solution I would recommend for all you
going forward
after we created the solution to the CP
we change our data ingestion system to
use all the gcp tools and like jka and
computer engine for processing power and
gcsm degree query for persisting layer
so Global play because after work loads
are now using SQL pipelines in bigquery
using data Farm
with composer Orchestra orchestrate all
the process together
we also use data catalog data studio and
vertex AI to explore a generating sites
it's worth noting that we use the this
transfer service to move all the
historical data
through Hadoop files
through cloud storage and was very easy
and help us a lot in the process
now our research and allocation is now
is not not driven by the peak moments
anymore we also scale everything with
the audience of the global plane so when
the global play has a higher audience we
have a lot allocate a lot more resources
when there are audience decrease with
decrease the release of the resources
in Disney solution was a great
Improvement for us in cost speed and
it's a lot faster for us now adding new
features in this pipeline like a new uh
segmentation or a new process in the in
the pipeline so that's what's helping us
a lot to evolve all the metrics that we
need for Global play